welcome to Hannity buckle up busy night
tonight the radical-socialist field 2020
Democrats is a dumpster fire filled with
hypocritical far-left candidates who are
willing to do and say anything for power
coming up tonight we will have full
coverage of this well frankly now really
disturbing field of politicians
including one unhinge candidate maybe
can guess who it is who's ready to lock
up American gun owners if they do not
turn their weapons over to the federal
government but first let's turn our
attention to a very important Hannity
watch as we investigate tonight the
investigators now tonight the tide is
turning dramatically after Thursday of
this week the gig is up for the hate
Trump media mob their Democratic allies
who for over two and a half years have
been pushing their tin foil hat
conspiracy theories and outright lies
about collusion now they don't know it
yet but it's done it is over it is
finished no collusion no obstruction
yeah there's gonna be a few that cling
to a few sentences offer more lies more
fake news more fake legal analysis but
in the end they are forever exposed for
the liars and partisan hacks that they
are they've put this country in danger
our constitutional republic in danger
now on Thursday the Muller report will
be released by the Attorney General Barr
and with only minor legally mandated
redactions and it will be what is the
final nail in the coffin to the
credibility of America's biggest Russia
collusion conspiracy theorists it's over
they don't know it yet that includes
so-called reporters at the Washington
Post and The New York Times they
actually won a Pulitzer Prize in 2018
for perpetrating a hoax
now that prize frankly should be revoked
I think it could be rewarded to the real
journalists the real investigative
reporters that we have every night on
this show and on my radio show the
people have been right the entire time
all along exposing layer-by-layer
every single issue involving what is the
biggest abuse of power corruption
scandal in history the only difference
is they have real evidence that has been
reported
over the course of two years on this
show and unlike so many in the media mob
we are not blinded by hate we follow the
truth the evidence due process now sadly
the same cannot be said about the media
mob now they reported their anti-trump
garbage lies propaganda over and over
and over again with their anonymous
sources and of course they're just doing
the Democrats bidding they're tied at
the hip manufactured crisis and on
Thursday they will do it predictably one
last time with all the phony lying
outrage they'll be able to manufacture
they want a bludgeon President Trump
which has been their goal all along by
any and all means necessary and they
have only one day left and by the way
just breaking moments ago Sarah Carter's
reporting that three of those Democrats
congressman Elijah Cummings Maxine
Waters and the Cowardly Adam Schiff
actually signed a secret pact behind
closed doors vowing to target president
Trump and subpoena all of his financial
and banking records oh by the way which
means more evidence they've even moved
on from collusion now this letter
obtained by Sarah Carter from
Congressman Jim Jordan it is now raising
serious concern over this secret
agreement to take down a president and
according to a congressional source
quote this is not how committees
normally operate the Democrats aren't
interested in legislating only attacking
the president Sarah Carter will join us
in a moment and give us that full report
but that's what the president's up
against and has been up against from day
one now if the president cured cancer
tonight and gave every American five
million dollars and adopted their sick
agenda they would still hate him here's
my prediction when the Muller report is
released on Thursday the same people
that have lied all along they're just
gonna find something anything in the
report to bludgeon the president by the
way it's not going to work again many on
the Left are ready speculating that the
30-plus hours of testimony from former
White House Counsel Don McCain is going
to be the linchpin providing the damning
evidence of wrongdoing okay let's do
something the media mob won't do let's
take an honest look at truth and facts
we know for a fact this
special counsel found no Russia
collusion between Trump or anyone in his
campaign matter of fact we have the
quote from the Muller report right here
this is from the molar report the
investigation did not establish that
members of the Trump campaign conspired
or coordinated with the Russian
government in its election interference
activities no collusion we also know for
a fact that three previous
investigations also cleared the
President and when it comes to claims
that the president obstructed justice we
also know for a fact that Muller did not
charge the president with obstruction
and we know that bar rod Rosen Stein the
DOJ is nonpartisan office of legal
counsel and yes in conjunction with
talking to the Muller team cleared the
president from any charges it's the fact
that President Trump did not fire mullet
they're gonna say well he wanted a
firearm but he didn't he's gonna say we
wanted a fire rod Rosen Stein in Jeff
Sessions okay he didn't he didn't impede
any investigation anywhere he didn't
interfere with general Flynn's case
except wishing that he wouldn't got get
in trouble and he got in trouble and as
Comey said the president is right to
fire him for any reason or no reason at
all now did the president talk about
these things yup
did he talk about him a lot yep the
witch-hunt the Democrats on Muller's
team firing sessions Rosen Stein and
hoping the general Flynn a 33 year
military hero wouldn't get hurt kind of
like all the deep state guys they talked
an awful lot about things too like
wearing a wire to spy on the president
they talked about trying to invoke the
25th amendment to remove a duly elected
president well they didn't do it but
they talked about it a lot so if a
president expresses frustration just
like those FBI DOJ guys about being
investigated or them not getting their
political way over a serious crime that
he didn't commit it's not obstruction
also there's no intent very important as
it relates to the law calling out the
Trump aiding Democrats who Muller
appointed to probe this whole thing that
is not obstruction frankly that was the
right thing to do and last but not least
firing Comey not obstruction and by the
way here's the
News president Trump's summed it up
perfectly when he tweeted out Muller the
AG and the AG based on Muller findings
and great intelligence have already
ruled no collusion no obstruction these
crimes were committed by crooked Hillary
the DNC dirty cops and others
investigate the investigators which we
have been doing the tables have finally
turned this is their last rubber bullet
and it'll hit and it'll fall to the
ground and it's all over now the Wall
Street Journal's bill McGurn smart guy
calling for a grand jury he's right to
investigate bad actors that are in the
deep state and abuse power quote if the
Federal Bureau of Investigation is to
recover its lost reputation by the way I
don't agree with that not rank-and-file
upper-echelon
the first item on attorney general bill
bars agenda must be to make good on
something that set off a frenzy when he
proposed it last week and honest the
county of the FBI spine yes they spied
on Trump they did many times many ways
any way the Attorney General has already
vowed to establish a team thankfully to
investigate our federal government
spying on the Trump campaign great
article today by Andrew McCarthy who'll
join us in a few minutes detailing some
of this potentially illicit surveillance
writing quote less than a year ago we
learned the Obama administration had
used a confidential informant to spy to
approach at least three Trump campaign
officials in the months leading up to
the 2016 election straining to find
proof that the campaign was complicit in
the Kremlin's hacking of democratic
emails now of course Andy McCarthy is
referring to Carter page George
papadopolis and Sam Clovis who were all
approached by an informant with the name
of Stephon halper that's only the tip of
the iceberg Trump's campaign associate
Carter page was also electronically
surveilled by the way can somebody teach
Comey what that means
after Comey and others signed off on
that FISA application the bulk of
information coming from the unverified
unverifiable uncorroborated dirty
Russian dossier paid for by Hillary
Clinton and let's not forget about the
nearly three hundred and fifty percent
increase in unmasking requests by top
officials in the election year of 2016
what did Obama know when did he know it
either way struck and paid say all the
decisions were made by Loretta Lynch
what did she know when did she know it
all so I think Susan Rice has questions
to answer Brennan clapper even creepy
Uncle Joe what do they all know when did
they all know it now soon we'll begin to
have the answers to these important
questions in a letter to the Director of
National Intelligence Congressman Jim
Jordan congressman mark meadows they
have now requested that 53 we've only
got like 753 closed-door testimony
transcripts be made public I'm sure
Jerry Nadler will join them because he
didn't want the release of the Starr
report already we have received the
testimony of Bruce or Lisa Paige Peter
struck James Baker other FBI and DOJ
officials who were involved in the
witch-hunt and it was against Donald
Trump the free pass given of course they
literally gave a get out of jail free
card because they liked Hillary they
thought the guy that interviewed her
Peter struck she should win a hundred
million to zero
yet she committed real crimes and we
have a massive amount of top-secret
classified material that was found on
that unsecured private server that was
managed by Platte River networks it was
in a bathroom closet she committed a
real crime and thus had a real intent to
obstruct justice by destroying the
evidence of that crime hence the 33,000
deleted acid-washed emails now the media
on Thursday they got to pretend they
care about obstruction of justice
meanwhile all of them will ignore the
biggest slam dunk obstruction of justice
case in history that's right Hillary's
case and just like Democrats remember
they believed all the Cavanaugh accusers
I believe they believe but their silence
is now deafening when it comes to the
lieutenant governor of Virginia oh he's
been accused of rape and violence sexual
assault so where are all the I believers
you know obstruction matters but only if
it's Trump not Hillary Clinton charges
of rape serious sexual assault only
matters if you're appointed by Trump but
not the Democratic lieutenant governor
of Virginia look at your screen a clear
violation of
the Espionage Act 18 USC 793 there's the
law why was Hillary cleared because the
investigation was rigged why did call me
instruct start writing in an exoneration
in May that in an interview heart till
July why did they take out gross
negligence the legal standard and
replace it with extreme carelessness why
did Peter struck allow to other people
in the interview room when he was
interviewing Clinton on July 2nd 2016
and called me exonerated her on July 5th
they had written that first in May what
did Bill Clinton and Loretta Lynch
really talk about on that secret meeting
on a tarmac in Phoenix
just before Hillary's was cleared did
Lynch the FBI did they work in concert
together to clear the Clintons did they
rig that investigation when it's obvious
she committed multiple felonies because
she was the one that should win a
hundred million a zero and Trump
supporters were nothing but smelly
Walmart voters from Hillary Clinton's
rigged investigation to spying on the
Trump campaign to committing a fraud and
FISA abuse to unmasking American
citizens and abusing the powerful tools
of intelligence to everything in between
we will now finally get the answers I
know the media won't go there because
then they'd have to admit they're wrong
they won't apologize they won't retract
they won't say Keith Kennedy and his
ensemble cast got it right don't hold
your breath we're gonna have a lot more
on this throughout the show but first we
also must report tonight on our Hannity
watch on the radical-socialist
20/20 Democrats it's been a very
revealing week for some of the far-left
sycophants trying to become president we
start with the current mayor of South
Bend Indiana yes that guy mayor Pete Oh
Peter
Buda hedge where Buddha judges his name
who said that the electoral college is
just one big Republican manipulation of
the system okay watch this if we realize
that this would be a fairer place if
everyone's vote counted the same and if
the way we picked our president was to
tally up all the votes and give to the
person who got the most votes then now
is a moment to make that change most
Americans don't want this most Americans
don't want the conservative
that we're now seeing the extreme agenda
they were seeing in Washington in fact
it is precisely for that reason that
they have to interfere with democracy
with things like voter suppression or
clinging on an electoral college that
overrules the will of the American
people it is precisely because the
American people by and large don't want
what they're selling that they are
relying on manipulations of our
political structure in order to keep
their agenda in play all right let me
educate mayor Pete Mayer Buddha judge
for a moment if he wants the good people
of his home state of Indiana have a
voice in the presidential election I
like the people from Indiana he should
probably rethink what is his
unconstitutional stance on the electoral
college because without our current
system New York New Jersey Illinois and
California they would decide every
national contest his state of Indiana
for that matter
New Hampshire Iowa South Carolina all
those red states down south they would
be totally ignored it wouldn't matter is
that what the good mayor wants
sadly mayor Pete is not the only
Democrat trampling on the US
Constitution California Congressman
Eric's wall well well he's actually
running on an 80 second amendment agenda
look at this now first he suggested the
federal government could easily disarm
Americans because it has nukes okay but
on Sunday he took it down a notch
and said that he just supports jailing
Americans who don't comply with his plan
to seize guns that he classifies as
dangerous here comes the government get
ready take a look
criminal prosecution for keeping assault
weapons what's the punishment for people
who don't hand in their guns do they go
to jail
well they would the reason I have
proposed this is because these weapons
are so devastating I've seen this as a
prosecutor in the cases that I've
prosecuted we've seen these in the
school shootings from Sandy Hook to
parkland and I was just at parkland
earlier this week doing a town hall
there but it's not just the violence
that they've caused it's the fear the
immeasurable fear that our children live
in because they are still on our streets
I want to get rid of that fear I want to
do what Australia did and New Zealand
just recently did I think this issue
just needs some bold leadership
to do it I want to get rid of the fear
of you not understanding the
Constitution or wanting to stack the
courts or Bernie Sanders last night on
this network actually suggesting oh yeah
a woman could have an abortion up to the
last minute like during birth or as the
Virginia Governor said first we'll
deliver the baby make sure that baby's
comfortable then mom gets to decide the
baby gets resuscitative help if needed